aquí tenemos una reacción muy
interesante de hierro con un poco de
ácido clorhídrico y supongamos que están
en solución acuosa como productos
obtenemos cloruro de hierro 2 y también
obtenemos un poco de hidrógeno molecular
los invito a pausar el vídeo en este
momento y traten de averiguar los
estados de oxidación para cada uno de
los elementos que componen estas
moléculas intenten escribir las
reacciones parciales y determinen quién
es oxidado y quién es reducido voy a
suponer que ya lo intentaron
ahora hagámoslo juntos de este lado
tenemos al hierro no está unido a otro
elemento así que no hay razón para que
caneo pierde electrones tiene un número
de oxidación de 0
ahora acá tenemos un hidrógeno unido al
cloro el cloro es muy electro negativo y
el hidrógeno casi no lo es entonces en
nuestro mundo iónico el cloro se queda
con todos los electrones así que tiene
un estado de oxidación uno negativo y el
hidrógeno pierde su electrón entonces
podemos escribir que tiene un número de
oxidación uno positivo si queremos lo
podemos escribir como uno más y éste
como uno menos aunque no se acostumbre
veamos el otro lado de la reacción ahora
nuestro hierro está unido a dos claros
pensemos en lo que normalmente haría el
cloro ya hemos visto al cloro se
encuentra en el grupo 7 de los elementos
encanta ganar electrones porque así
puede completar los 8 electrones de
valencia en su capa electrónica su
número de oxidación cuando está unido a
otras cosas es de 1 negativo aunque como
no lo estamos escribiendo como súper
índice lo podemos escribir como menos 1
supongamos que cada cloro toma un
electrón entonces tienen un estado de
oxidación de 1 negativo si cada uno
tiene un estado de oxidación de 1
negativo y toda la molécula debe ser
neutral
entonces el hierro debe de tener si dos
veces uno negativo es 2 negativo
entonces para que la molécula sea
neutral el hierro debe de tener un
número de oxidación 2 positivo por eso
se les llama cloruro
y qué me dicen de los hidrógenos no hay
razón para que un hidrógeno acaparen los
electrones del otro o permita que otro
acá pare sus electrones entonces cada
hidrógeno tiene un estado de oxidación
de cero
ahora pensemos en las reacciones
parciales para poder decir cuál es el
elemento oxidado y cuál es el reducido
empecemos con el hierro
del lado derecho el hierro tiene un
número de oxidación de 0 y del lado
izquierdo el hierro termina con un
estado de oxidación 2 positivo como
pasamos de 0 a un número positivo bueno
necesitamos perder electrones cada vez
que se pierde un electrón el número de
oxidación aumenta ya sea una carga
supuesta o una real se vuelve más
positiva así que el hierro pierde
electrones como ha perdido electrones
aquí los tenía y aquí los perdió dónde
quedaron los electrones justo aquí más
dos electrones y como le llamamos a algo
cuando pierde electrones bueno decimos
que fue oxidado le ocurrió lo que
normalmente hace el oxígeno a otros
quitar electrones
el hierro ha sido oxidado
ahora pensemos en los hidrógenos al
principio tenemos dos hidrógenos con un
número de oxidación uno más y del lado
derecho
también tenemos dos hidrógenos si no
fueran los mismos
la reacción no estaría balanceada cuál
es el número de oxidación ahora cero
entonces como pasamos de un número de
oxidación positivo a uno neutral hay que
ganar electrones la única manera de que
la carga ya sea supuesta o real baje es
ganando electrones así que cada
hidrógeno ganó un electrón como tenemos
dos hidrógenos en total gana 2
electrones
y como le decimos a algo que gana
electrones bueno reducción es ganar
el hidrógeno ha sido reducido el
hidrógeno fue reducido
y qué me dicen del cloro del lado
izquierdo
el cloro tiene un estado de oxidación 1
negativo y del lado derecho también es
uno negativo en ambos lados tenemos dos
claros entonces en esta reacción el
cloro no fue reducido ni oxidado
definitivamente tenemos una reacción
óxido reducción o también llamada
reacción redox porque tenemos algo que
es oxidado y algo que es reducido el
hierro fue oxidado por el hidrógeno y el
hidrógeno fue reducido por el hierro